good morning Hank it's Sunday today I'm
going to tell you five reasons why I
think the presidential election in Iran
was fraudulent but first we have to have
an election of our own nerdfighters the
beard should I keep it or shave it vote
in comments I realize this isn't an
important election but unlike Iran I
will at least adhere to the results
okay so first two sentences of
background on Iran Iran is an Islamic
Republic which means that while the
position of president is important it's
not that important because ultimately
Iran's domestic and international
affairs are always decided by a Council
of religious leaders which is led by the
Ayatollah Khomeini every time I Ron is a
presidential election like 37,000
moderates try to run for president but
they are barred from doing so which has
historically often led to low voter
turnout because people don't show up to
vote for guys they don't like okay hey
so a couple days ago Iran had a
presidential election and as you may
know the incumbent president of Iran is
a guy named Mahmoud Ahmadinejad who to
use a somewhat technical political
science term is a bit of a douche nozzle
and in this election there were 37,000
moderates who weren't allowed to run
just like usual but there were also two
quasi reformist candidates including a
former prime minister of Iran named Mir
Hossein Mousavi so on election day a
stunning 85 percent of eligible voters
voted and a couple hours after the polls
closed the interior ministry announced
that Ahmadinejad was winning with 63% of
the vote which Hank at least as far as
I'm concerned it's just a little tiniest
bit impossible I maintain that akhmad
Energy odd and possibly supreme leader
Ayatollah Khomeini stole the election
it's not a fatwa I smell on me Peck I'm
not saying that this election was
invalid because a douchenozzle happen to
win it douche-nozzles win elections all
the time all over the world what I'm
saying is that there's just a lot of
things that don't add up like number one
Tabriz the Reformers candidate Mousavi
is from a city called Tabriz and
historically the city of Tabriz always
votes for mr. Mousavi or whoever the guy
is from his ethnic group who's running
and yet inexplicably in this election
they apparently voted 2 to 1 for Ahmed
Energy odd I mean heck it's the
equivalent of John McCain winning
Chicago reason to 2005 Hank the last
time Iran had a presidential election
was in 2005 and even though a ton of
people didn't show up at the polls
because they were mad about their
candidates not being on the ballot
Ahmed energon who was less crazy and
more popular than he is now still wasn't
able to avoid a runoff which leads me to
reason 3 turnout the turnout in this
election was ridiculously high by
Iranian standards and in the last twenty
years
every
time there has been high turnout a
reformist candidate has won all of the
pre-election polls indicated that the
only chance Ahmed energon had was if the
turnout was extremely low number four
superhuman counting Hank despite the
incredibly high turnout the interior
ministry managed to announce the
election results within like two hours
of polls closing Hank they counted like
10 million more ballots 30 times faster
than they ever have in the past it's
almost like they weren't counting them
at all and number 5 the possible
acknowledgment Hank because the Iranian
government is started to kick out
foreign journalists and shut down
websites it's a little hard to get
reliable information even for people
like me who have spent the entire day
reading Iranian Twitter's link in the
sidebar
but many people from inside Mousavi's
campaign are reporting that the Interior
Ministry called him to say that he had
won the election shortly before that
same interior ministry went on TV and
announced that Mousavi had in fact lost
the election peg we still don't know the
whole story about the elections it's
possible that somehow they weren't
rigged but I do hope that the government
of Iran has the decency to honor the
will of its people as it says in the
Quran truly God does not guide those who
transgress and lie Hank like I said I
have links in the sidebar to the
Twitter's of young Iranians who are
tweeting through all of this
you often hear that nothing interesting
can be said in 140 characters obviously
the people who say that aren't following
the young Iranian woman who just wrote
if Iran sleeps tonight it will sleep
forever